hello again  and uh this is a quernstone  now coinstone is a domestic version of  what a mill is all about  it has two stones one rubber against the  other and bedstone is one that stays  static at the bottom and the one the top  one is rotated rotated by hand in this  particular case  and each one is uh cut with uh with  grooves  so they can crush the stone across the  grain against the stone  and eventually work its way across the  stone and turning itself into flour  the grain is poured into the center of  the stones you see the hole in the top  of this one  and then get hold of the handle and just  keep turning the funny part about  grinding flour everything goes backwards  everything is going to clockwise  uh how that comes about probably through  the gearing or and  the cut of the groves will make a  difference but you wind it backwards  and as i say the grain works itself  across the stones getting finer and  finer  finer